I have to quickly ask you about dancing
the Stars yes of course no spring season
I know I was when the news came out I
was incredibly surprised and I knew it
was a bit of a conversation there was a
buzz about it because of course we have
Idol now on ABC and we did try a four
week season last year and it was not a
fan favorite it was not a fan favorite
our athlete season adult was great which
is two too short for us so I don't know
if they are planning anything that might
be a surprise in the summer maybe
there's juniors I don't have info don't
quote me on it this is again I heard
rumblings rumblings of we're trying to
figure out what we want to do with that
spring summer time for us but we are
having a season 28 we're going to
confirm that date and this show is such
a fan favorite I mean Hanna mine it's
not going anywhere we're gonna do 30 35
maybe 40 five seasons I'll have babies
and be married by that I've retired by
that point but you know this is Dancing
with the Stars isn't going anywhere and
I'm actually kind of excited now it's
all settled in that people are gonna
miss us for a little second because 2018
had a lot of Dancing with the Stars
there was like three seasons racing in
together yeah I did see online I love
Bobby bones
you were Bobby bones but he got a lot of
hate yes when the scheduling shift was
announced why was that it's not his
fault it was like a new influx of people
saying that Bobby broke the show I mean
first of all that's ridiculous to think
that that could even be the case but
honestly I think people with shorts are
passionate about last season and their
favorites and Bobby came out on top with
his fan base and how many people were
behind him I love people's passion for
the show I wish they didn't have to go
online and direct it to him like it's
his fault
because it really isn't but I love how
passionate people are and again that
passion and the fact that we are still a
conversation is the reason that Dancing
with the South will be around for
another X amount of see yeah
going anywhere people love it and I love
that they're passionate about it maybe a
little less Prasanna tea and a little
less you know a few other things but
Bobby can handle it and so can I now
that you do have a mirror ball do you
have more saying who your partner is
geez I wish that was okay now wouldn't
that be nice yeah that is uh probably
not
I think I'm still at the mercy of
whoever they want to give me which is
totally fine they've always done amazing
by me I've had some incredible
incredible partners that are all family
to me now is there a bucket list Zac
Efron yes how do we make that happen I
don't think I can happen you would win
your second mirror ball probably
probably yeah I'll go I'm going for
back-to-back it's Harley yeah it is
gonna happen
[Music]